Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
says he will stay in the race for
re-election despite public anger over
images that show him wearing blackface
Trudeau said last night he deeply
regrets his actions with which happened
before he got involved in politics
Jamie yuccas is outside the Canadian
Parliament building in Ottawa Jamie how
are these blackface photos affecting
Trudeau's campaign well it depends who
you talk to Tony good morning throughout
his political life Trudeau has portrayed
himself as a champion for racial
equality and diversity but some
political observers say these newly
released images could hurt his
reputation and credibility and
potentially sway key swing voters with
Election Day just over a month away
Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
spent Thursday night again apologizing
to voters and asking for forgiveness
Trudeau is on the defensive after three
photos in a short video of him in
blackface decades ago emerged over the
past two days darkening your face is
always unacceptable because of the
racist history of blackface I should
have understood that then and I never
should have done it the first photo of
Trudeau was published Wednesday taken in
2001 when he was a 29 year old teacher
attending an Arabian Nights party the
Prime Minister then admitted to
performing Deo a traditional Jamaican
song in blackface when he was in high
school and on Thursday a video of
Trudeau also in blackface surfaced a
government official says it was taken in
the early 1990s
Trudeau's political opponents say his
actions were unacceptable what we're see
now is an ongoing pattern of behavior
that's really gonna hurt Canadians
they're gonna see the Prime Minister
mocking the realities that so many
Canadians live with it's what you would
call a real political bombshell Tando me
Charles is covering next month's
election for the Toronto Star and his
main opponent are neck and neck in most
polls now with this the conservative
opponent of Justin Trudeau does not need
to win a lot of votes what's striking is
how polarizing Justin Trudeau is here in
Canada the people I spoke with either
loved him or say their negative feelings
are validated by the scandal it could
tarnish his legacy as well as his
families his wildly popular father
Pierre Trudeau served as Canada's Prime
Minister twice in the 60s through the
80s Anthony all right Jamie yuccas in
Ottawa this morning thanks Jamie